this team has had successes but much
remains to be done
Superboy Miss Martian Beast Boy your
alpha bar zone has called the Mars he
needs help
Tigers Kid Flash bumblebee Guardian your
beta legs Corp is bringing out the reach
soft drink under a new name we need
proof business as usual
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my Titan Season 1 Young
Justice season 3 video they announced a
whole bunch of stuff at Comic Con so
I'll break it down including cast
members that they've just announced for
Titans there's a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so the big stuff first they just
cast Raven on the new Titans TV series
they won't be filming the pilot till I
think it's September so she's officially
the first person that they publicly
announced whether or not they've
actually found some of the other actors
so we might find out who our Nightwing
Starfire and Beast Boy are they're the
only four that they've confirmed for the
pilot so I think they're trying to keep
the main cast relatively small for at
least the first couple of episodes then
they might introduce more Titans
characters later on but if you remember
how a lot like the flash character
started out it wasn't a huge team when
they first started it was Caitlin Cisco
in Harrison wells who was secretly the
reverse-flash so relatively small teams
starting out that slowly grows over time
as you can see the Raven is really young
she's going to be between 11 and 13 on
the series they're Beast Boy is also
going to be around that age too but
Nightwing and Starfire are both going to
be in their mid to late 20s so think
like Oliver clean Barry Allen age a lot
of you saw this and we're like wait are
they doing Teen Titans what's the deal
with this so just hang tight for the
rest of the month and if everybody wants
to know who's going to play Nightwing in
how's this going to interact with the
Nightwing movie which they kind of
skipped over at Comic Con they've
already said the big reason they didn't
talk about Nightwing at comic-con is
just because they don't want to give the
movie a date before they've completely
figured it out like they're not going to
rush it along they want to make an
awesome movie odds are they'll drop some
off cycle news and we might get a
concept teaser by Comic Con I know you
also want to know about Deathstroke is
he going to be a crossover character
they haven't said anything more about it
being connected or not
connected to the arrowverse I'm assuming
for now that there just won't even
address it during season one because
they're doing a two part death stroke
episode that will tell his origin story
during the first half of arrow later
this season so it just sounds like he's
going to be earmarked for arrow things
this year maybe when they get to Titan
season 2 then they'll worry about
arrowverse death stroke stuff but they
have confirmed that Titans will be 13
episodes so it sounds like it'll be a
relatively self-contained story and then
they might be able to broaden it later
on but obviously they haven't done
season 1 yet so we don't really know
what they're going to do with season 2
depending on how successful it is or
what happens with this streaming service
and if you're worried about this whole
DC streaming service don't worry that
much if the service itself fails but the
show is good then another network will
just pick it up and they'll continue to
make it with the cat but on to the Young
Justice stuff so there was a legit Young
Justice season 3 panel at comic-con
season 3 is being called outsiders so
even if you haven't read it most of you
have probably heard of the outsiders
team it's usually referred to as Batman
and the outsiders they're just a group
of people who do the things that the
Justice League can't do they infiltrate
other organizations which is basically
what the team did when they were
infiltrating the light during season 2
we have arrived with a final shipment of
proletarians congratulations thank you
Father
initiating phase two they've recorded
seven episodes but this will get you
guys excited
they have 26 total episodes in season 3
that's right 26 episodes of Young
Justice next year so as you can see they
showed up all this concept footage of
the new roster it's grown quite a bit
you have static Kid Flash Robin Wonder
Girl spoiler as in Stephanie Brown
spoiler Blue Beetle 13 who is the name
of a character from the comics that
somewhat magic base she shows up during
House of Mystery so she's a magic user
heroine Arsenal in Beast Boy this is
Artemis Superboy and then this is
actually black lightning so a lot of
people saw this and they were like is
this Aqualad is this what he looks like
No Aqualad was not featured in any of
the concept footage that
showed off but Kari Payton was recording
episodes earlier this year
Aqualad is still part of season three
they just said that he's off doing his
own thing kind of what he was doing
during season two
although Artemis was along for the ride
on that they drop some story details
they said that the end of season two was
not a cliffhanger so there will be a
time jump when they pick up in season
three they didn't say how much time has
gone by but it's the same thing from
season 1 to season 2 like they just jump
forward in time
everybody's doing different things and
then within the first couple of episodes
they subtly reference where everybody
went and what they've been doing this
whole time they did not confirm when
it's going to drop no premiere date yet
just sometime during 2018 they didn't
say much about the DC streaming service
I think they're still figuring the
mechanics of that out behind the scenes
and you know what the price point is
going to be are they going to charge for
it is it going to be ad supported what
countries is it going to be available in
so they'll probably make separate
announcements about that early next year
I'm not expecting to hear a whole lot
about that for the rest of this year
there were a lot of Red Hood questions
because people were like if you got Tim
Drake this whole time what happened to
Jason Todd is he dead is he going to
come back as Red Hood during the series
they also didn't say anything about
wallet coming back but obviously it's
heavily implied that he's in the
speedforce
and it'll come back at some point but if
you're wondering about the costume here
this is still impulse from last year he
just has a slightly upgraded version of
the costume like everybody else
they said that because it's on the
streaming service they can do more
hardcore stories they can make
everything look a little bit better they
can take the time to just make it a much
more enjoyable series so the episode
sound like they're going to be awesome
we might get some teasers later this
year even if they don't announce when
it's going to drop believe all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments or if you have any big
questions about the series there's still
a lot that we don't know especially
about the Titan series too but I've
already done a couple videos about
Titans that I'll link at the end of this
obviously there's new Game of Thrones
I'll be posting this weekend along with
Rick and Morty but congratulations to
the latest flash ring giveaway winner
Jamie McSherry please private message be
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for everything you can click here to
learn all about what's going on with the
flash and you can click here for brand
new Game of Thrones thank you so much
for watching everybody
they awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you